foreign
I've been living with this character for
eight years
we laughed cheered cried together
the core pillar of this franchise is
figuring out who you really are and
what's worth fighting for
Creed Three I wanted to know what
adonis's limits were so to be able to
finally step behind the camera
continue to elevate and evolve this
story it's something I'm externally
grateful for
in my man can I help you you'll remember
me huh Damien as a Storyteller you
really put a piece of yourself into your
films from personal desires and goals to
shortcomings failures mistakes here's
what happened with you too he was like
brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that
Creed 3 it's not just your typical
boxing movie
we really want to take advantage of the
emotional journey of the characters and
put that into the ring and have it pay
off in a physical way something is going
on with you Damien was like family
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find him do what I gotta do
some of my methods you might disagree
with me this is the first sports film to
be shot on IMAX cameras
with the IMAX experience you can take in
the environment in a way that you
normally wouldn't
be able to see every beat of sweat every
impact the ripples in the skin the
sounds of the footsteps the punches the
music the lack of sound and really
immerse yourself into the entire world
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me everybody has a past
everybody has things that they wish they
could have done differently
so to be able to see a character like
Adonis go through some of those things I
hope audiences walk away feeling
inspired and have the courage to do
something that you normally wouldn't do
that I need you to make all your fear
fear they're going to give
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is I want people to walk away from
this movie feeling better than they did
when they walked in I think that's
something that's powerful about Cinema
[Applause]
[Music]